PROFESSOR: This will
be qualitative insights
on the wave function.
It's qualitative,
and it's partially
quantitative of course,
insights into, let's say,
real energy eigenstates.
So whenever you have a
problem and a potential,
we have what is called the total
energy, the kinetic energy,
and the potential energy.
So you have the energy, which
is total, equal kinetic energy
plus the potential energy.
Now, the potential
energy, as you've seen,
sometimes depends on position.
We did piecewise
continuous end potentials,
but they could be
more complicated
and do funny things.
So this is a function of x.
And classically speaking,
we speak of the energy.
You see in quantum mechanics,
the energy is an observable
and is the result of a
measurement with a permission
operator.
Sometimes there could be
uncertainty, sometimes not.
But in classical physics, which
this intuition will come from,
you have a total energy.
It is conserved.
It's equal to potential
energy and kinetic energy.
That will also depend
on where the particle is
in the potential.
Let's do a very simple case.
Coordinate x, a potential.
v of x, this based the
potential. v of x, it's
a constant, nothing
that complicated.
And suppose you
have a total energy.
Now, the total energy
in classical mechanics
is conserved.
So when I draw a
line, I'm not implying
that is a function of x,
that sometimes the energy is
like that.
No, it's just a number
there that I fixed.
Here is the energy.
And then wherever you
move, if the particle,
the classical particle,
is here, then it
has some potential energy, v
of x, and some kinetic energy,
k of x, building up
the total energy.
Classically, the kinetic
energy determines the momentum.
The kinetic energy
is p squared over 2m.
Now, the kinetic energy
In this case, the kinetic
energy is a constant.
The momentum will be a constant.
And then what we really want
to just say something about
is the wave function.
Well, but if we note
the momentum classically
it's a momentum p, we can
infer the Broglie wavelength
of the particle.
And that the Broglie
wavelength would be h over p.
And that's for
the wave function.
So we should expect
a wave function
that has a wave length
equal to lambda.
After all, that is
what the Broglie did.
And from the Broglie, you
got the Schrodinger equation.
The Schrodinger
equation, in fact,
says this, if you
look at it again.
So if you look at
the wave function.
Well, it must have
wavelength lambda.
And therefore, I'm talking
about real wave function.
So it could be a
cosine or a sine that
has that wavelength lambda.
Of course in quantum
mechanics, a cosine or a side
doesn't have exactly--
it's not an eigenstate
of momentum.
But it's an eigenstate
state of energy.
And we want to plug
eigenstates of energy.
So you will have something
like that, with that lambda.
And that's intuition.
You go from the diagram
to a kinetic energy,
from a kinetic
energy to a momentum,
from a momentum to a wavelength,
and that's the wavelength
of your energy eigenstate.
And maybe it's a good idea that
you try to convince yourself
this is true by looking again
at the Schrodinger equation.
For this simple case
of a constant potential
and an energy that is big,
you will find this result
very quickly.
But let's do now a more
interesting case, in which here
is x.
And the potential is a
growing function of x.
And there's a total
energy here still.
So if you are at
some point here,
here is the potential of x.
And now, this is k of x.
And now comes the
interesting thing.
You see, as your particle,
or whatever particle,
is moving here,
the kinetic energy
is decreasing as you
move to the right.
So the kinetic
energy [INAUDIBLE]
velocity and slows down,
slows down, slows down.
The kinetic energy is
becoming smaller and smaller.
Therefore the momentum is
And therefore the wavelength,
the Broglie wavelength,
must be becoming
bigger and bigger.
Now that is not exact
because you really
have to solve the Schrodinger
equation to do this.
But intuitively, you know that
if a potential is constant,
this is absolutely true.
The kinetic energy,
and the momentum,
and the Broglie waveform
have related in this way.
It will be sort of true,
or approximately true,
if the potential is
not changing that fast.
Because then it's
approximately constant.
So there's a notion the
slowly changing potential,
in which we can talk about the
k of x that is decreasing as we
move to the right, a p of
x that is also decreasing,
and a lambda of x that
would be increasing,
a wave with the Broglie
wavelength that is increasing.
Now I should have
written in here, maybe,
k of x, p of x, lambda of x.
This is decreasing,
decreasing, increasing.
So I can plot it here.
And I would say, well, I don't
know exactly how this goes.
But maybe it's the
wavelength is small.
And then the
wavelength is becoming
bigger, something like that.
Well, the wavelength's becoming
bigger in the energy eigenstate
that you will find is true.
But there's also the question
whether the amplitude
of the wave will change or not.
So we'll answer that
in a couple of minutes.
But the Broglie
wavelength now is becoming
a function of position.
Now, you know that solving
the Schrodinger equation now
with an arbitrary potential
is a difficult thing.
With a linear potentially
it's a difficult problem,
in which the exact solution
exists in terms of Airy
functions and things like that.
So this can only be an
approximate statement
that the Broglie wavelength
is becoming bigger and bigger,
because the momentum is
becoming smaller and smaller.
But it's a very
useful statement.
And whenever you look at
wave functions of potentials,
you see that thing happening.
Questions?
Let me draw another diagram
that illustrates these issues.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
So let's draw a general
picture of a potential
now, so we can make
a few features here.
So here it is.
We'll have a potential that
is like this, v of x, maybe
some energy, e, and that's it.
Now what happens
classically, well,
if your particle
has some energy,
you know already
this part is v of x.
This is k of x.
There is a potential
energy and kinetic energy.
The kinetic energy cannot
become negative classically.
So the particle cannot go to the
left of this point called xl,
x to the left.
So this region, x left, is
the classically forbidden.
Similarly on the right,
you cannot go beyond here.
Because then you would have
negative kinetic energy.
So this is an x right.
And everything to the
right [INAUDIBLE],
x right, is also
classical forbidden.
These points, x
left and x right,
are called turning points.
Because those are
the points where
a particle, a
classical particle,
if it lives in this potential,
has to bounce back and turn.
As we mentioned, at
any general point,
you have v of x and k of x.
And this point, for
example, is the point
with maximum k of x
or maximum velocity.
This is the point where the
particle is moving the fastest.
And it always slows down as
it reaches the turning point.
Because the kinetic energy is
becoming smaller and smaller.
So as we said, if you
had a constant potential,
this would be the solution.
It's constant p,
constant lambda,
nice, simple wave function.
If it's not constant, well,
nothing is guaranteed.
But if it's sufficiently
constant or slowly varied,
then you're in good shape.
Now what is the meaning
of slowly varying?
The meaning of
slowly varying has
to be said in a precise way.
And this is what
leads eventually
to the so-called WKB
approximation of quantum
mechanics.
Because we're giving you
the first results of this
approximation that you
can understand classically
how they go.
To mean that you have a
slowly varying potential,
is a potential whose
percentage change
is small in the
relevant distances.
So it's the change
in the potential
over the relevant
distance must be small
compared to the potential.
But what is a relevant distance?
If we use intuition
from quantum mechanics,
it's at the Broglie
wavelength at any point.
That is what the
quantum particle sees.
So what we need
is that the change
in the potential over at
the Broglie wavelength--
take the derivative
multiply it by that.
The Broglie wavelength
must be much smaller
than the potential itself.
And notice, of course, the
potential is a function of x.
And even lambda is a
function of x there
at the Broglie wavelength.
Now, an exact solution will
not be a sine or a cosine.
So to say has a precise defined
wavelength is an approximation.
It is the approximation
of slowly varying.
But it's a nice approximation.
And this lambda
is the lambda that
would come as h over p of x.
And h over p of x is
the square root of 2m
times the kinetic
energy over h squared--
no, it's just that,
the square root of 2mk.
Square root of 2mk of x.
So the idea is that
you can roughly
say that the Broglie wavelength
here is of some value here.
The momentum is small if the
Broglie wavelength is large.
And so when you draw
things, you adjust that.
You say, OK, here,
the momentum is large.
Therefore the Broglie
wavelength is small.
So you write a short
wavelength thing.
And then it becomes longer
wavelength and then shorter.
And you just tried
to get some insight
into how this thing looks.